INSTRUCTOR: Hey,
everybody, welcome back.
So in today's video, we're
going to actually move
towards deploying
applications to the web.
We're going to do this
in a stepwise fashion.
So there's not going to
be everything all at once.
But I want us to
start to build up
the pieces that go into
developing and building
a modern web application.
So step one is really
just, what does it
look like to host
something on the internet?
We've talked about this,
how our EC2 instance
and in general, any server can
be a website, or host a website.
So like my laptop right
now, technically speaking,
if I open it up to
the outside world
and I had an HTML file
sitting here on my computer,
I could make that a website.
That could be a
public facing website.
Now granted, that would mean
that any traffic coming in
would have to go through
my home Wi-Fi network.
I'd have to leave my
computer on at all times.
So it's probably not the most
secure or reliable thing to do,
but it does work.
A single computer can
serve as a web server.
And so that's what
we're going to do today.
We're going to use EC2
instances as the single web
server, with the
ultimate goal to say,
let's push up a version of our
resume that is always online,
that we can send
somebody a link to.
You can link somebody
to it if you wanted to.
And so it'll be an
actual practical thing.
I mean, it's up to you again
how deep you go into this,
how professional you
want to make that.
And it's also up to
your skill level.
We're not going to expect
that you have any programming
background to do this.
But if you do, if you've already
gotten some web design or web
development skills,
you're welcome to leverage
them here and honestly,
throughout this module
that we're talking about web
development and deployment.
So no expectations, but I would
say make of it what you can
and what makes sense to you and
where you're at in your career.
So with that, I'll slide
myself out of the way here
and I'll go to
the bottom corner.
Let's anchor it here.
OK, that's small, perfect.
So yeah, let's
jump right into it.
Right here, you can see I'm
on the EC2 console or the AWS
console, and I'm
going to open up EC2
because I want to
launch an EC2 instance.
So it's the same process
as we've seen many times.
Click Launch Instance.
I'm just going to call
mine testserver_webdev.
Call it whatever you want.
If you're going
to leave it live,
I'd name it something
intentional so that it's
like, hey, this is live.
Maybe call it the resume server.
Maybe we'll do that
since we're going
to say this is for our resume.
So that way, if I'm ever
going through and trying
to clear out resources, I
know to leave this one live,
for example.
So I'm going to pick Ubuntu.
Something that is free tier
eligible, doesn't really matter.
22.04 24.04 are
free tier right now.
It depends on when you're
watching this video, what
is at the free tier.
So I'm just going to the
free tier eligible one.
Same thing with the
instance type T2 micro.
This is something
to note though,
that the smaller
the instance is,
the less traffic it can support.
For what we're doing as far as
hosting a resume for somebody
to occasionally look at, this is
going to be plenty sufficient.
But this is why we want
to be able to learn
how to develop and
deploy in the cloud
because then we can actually
leverage the benefits here
and say, hey, if we
have a lot of traffic,
let's scale up either the
number of instances hosting
our website, or the
size of the instances,
or whatever that might be.
So it is the flexibility
of it that we like.
But for now, I'm going to
stick at the free tier level.
If you don't have an
existing key pair,
you can create a
new one, or I'm just
going to use the existing one.
Remember, to create
a new one, all
you do is click
Create New Key Pair.
I do RSA and then dot PEM.
And if you click
Create Key Pair,
it'll download that to your
computer, the private key.
And then that will be necessary
to connect to the instance
securely.
Now, this is where
we're actually
to make the first changes
under network settings.
You can also create this as
a permanent security group
so you don't have to keep
recreating a new one each time,
but there's no cost
associated with it.
So either way, what
I'm going to do
is I'm going to select allow
SSH traffic from anywhere.
That's the default.
We want to be able to
SSH into our instance.
That's how we've been
connecting to them.
And then I'm also
going to check allow
HTTP traffic from the internet.
We could also select HTTPS,
though we're not going
to set up a secure website.
There's another couple of
steps we have to do to do that.
And for what we're
doing here, it
doesn't really make sense to put
that extra effort in right now.
But long-term, we want to
know how to do that or want
to explore that.
Again, from this side,
all we have to do
is select this button from
the EC2 instance side.
All we have to do is
select this button.
It's more about the security
certificates we have to enable
and all that good stuff.
So we'll get to that
when we get to that.
For now, HTTP
traffic is just fine.
Storage, the default 8
gigs is perfectly fine.
And we can leave
everything else the same.
So we'll just click
launch instance.
Now I'm going to click
over here to this
while we wait for it to launch.
A couple things to note.
We're going to be
connecting to it
via our public IPv4
address or the DNS,
so the domain name server.
So you can see this
one is aside from being
a big alphanumeric
string, EC2, notice
that this is actually
just the IP address here,
the public IP address.
It'll be the region and then
.compute.amazon.aws.com.
So if you want to give a "dot
com" or URL to get to this,
that's how you could do it.
Or you can connect to
it from the IP address,
doesn't really matter.
Practically, if you wanted
to keep this live long-term,
we'd want to assign a
domain name to that.
That's not something we're
going to do in this lecture.
But to give you a short, brief
10 second intro to what you
need to do, and there's plenty
of resources online to do this.
Basically, what you
would do-- if you
think about what a website is,
again, I put in google.com.
Now, if I go to
google.com, what I'm
actually saying is that
domain name, Google.com, it
is registered in a
domain name registry,
and that maps to an IP address
or really a range of IP
addresses.
But simplify it for a second.
Google.com is assigned
to a single IP
address, the same way
this domain name is
assigned to this IP address.
So what will happen
is if you want
to have your own
domain name that says,
sharad.joke, or sharad.com,
sharad.org, whatever it is, then
you would basically
purchase a domain
name from some sort of
domain name registry.
And they'll usually
have a platform.
For example, I use-- and again,
I don't care which platform you
use to do this, I use Namecheap
just because it was one
that I happened upon.
And so if I wanted to
do sharadresume.ai--
dot AI is an option nowadays
as a domain name as opposed
to dot com or dot org.
But you can see there's a
bunch of different ones.
That would cost me 80 bucks
a year to own that name.
But there are also cheaper ones.
Dot org is 7 bucks.
Dot net is 5 bucks a year.
And there's also
more expensive ones.
310 bucks a year for dot game.
So it's an interesting
marketplace idea.
But the whole point is once
you've purchased a domain name,
then basically, what you'll do
is you'll go into your account
and you'll say, OK, this IP
address of my instance here--
and let's make sure
this is launched, yep.
So this IP address
of my instance,
I want to register
it to this name such
that if somebody goes
to sharadresume.com,
or dot AI, whatever it is, then
that maps to this IP address
and so it'll send
them to our website.
So that's really all you have to
do to put a domain name on this.
And I think there's even a tool
within AWS to do this as well.
So keep that in mind.
But for right now, we don't
need to worry about that.
We're just going to connect
to that via the IP address.
So let's click connect.
And this is the same again
as we've seen before.
So I'll copy this here.
And then I'll
launch my terminal.
Let me move this
one out of the way.
And I guess I shouldn't
have the secret key.
You can ignore that.
If you saw that secret
key, that's fine.
That's an old
deleted one anyways.
It was from a previous lesson
I was doing in class here.
So let's go this way.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're going to say, OK, great,
paste our SSH key in there.
And now, remember, if you
hadn't done this before,
if you haven't connected
to this instance
before, you'll need to go
to wherever it's downloaded.
So if it's in your
downloads folder,
if you've moved it to your dot
SSH folder, whatever it is,
you'll need to go to
wherever this secret key is
on your terminal
or in powershell,
and then you'll need
to run that command.
Also, if you're on a Mac or
any sort of Linux based device,
you'll also need to run this
CH mod command before you can
run the other command first.
So just keep that in mind.
It's the same process.
Feel free to go back through
the EC2 connection video
from before if you want
to look more into that.
So let's increase the
size of this here.
OK, great.
So now, we're in our
Ubuntu environment.
The first thing we want to
do is run sudo apt update -y.
So all this is
going to do is it's
going to basically update
the registry of libraries
in the background to make sure
that we are able to grab--
because we're going to
need install some software
to do this connection.
This is just going to
make sure we have that
available in the background.
Sorry, we'll wait a couple
seconds for that to finish here.
And then the next
thing we're going to do
is we're going to run
sudo apt install apache2.
So sudo apt install apache2.
And we'll say yes on that.
Now, what Apache is, is it's
a free-- it's open source
software.
And what it does is
it says or it handles
the communication that
says, hey, this person
has put in our URL
or our IP address.
They've come to
connect to our website.
And we want them to receive the
page, the file, the HTML file.
Let's say we're going to
build an HTML website,
we want them to
receive this HTML file
because they sent this request.
So we're going to respond
with the HTML file
when we receive a request.
Apache is the web server.
Apache is the thing that's
going to handle that.
It's going to say,
OK, well, there
is a HTTP request that was
sent to this IP address.
Apache is going to do the
bookkeeping and say, OK, great,
that means they get
this file and we're
going to send it back to them.
And so that's why
we need to install
apache or some other type
of web server to do that.
Apache is just an open
source one to do that.
So if you ever just
search apache web server,
you can see here, free open
source, Apache license,
all that good stuff, tons
of details and documentation
about that.
So that's just there for you
if you want to reference.
But there's nothing uniquely
special about that for us here.
OK, so we have that now.
Now, the first
order of business is
we are going to
enable a firewall.
That's just going to provide the
extra layer of security to say,
hey, only people allowed or only
traffic from specific directions
can be allowed into our website.
We've actually already
set that up by default.
If you come back over to your
instance, you can see it here.
Come down to security, you'll
notice that inbound rules,
we're allowing traffic
through port 22 and traffic
through port 80.
These ports are exactly
what they sound like.
Again, it's like
a shipping port.
They say that, hey, OK, if
somebody comes to our IP address
from anywhere, that's
what this source defines.
It says, from
anywhere on the web,
if they come to our IP
address at this specific port,
trying to come in through
port 22, that's OK.
Now, there might be an
extra layer of security
because port 22 is
our SSH connection.
So you notice when you try to
SSH in to your EC2 instance,
it works just fine.
It says, hey, you're welcome
to come in through this way,
but you do have to
put in, or you do
have to have the private key.
That's where we
create the key pair.
Similarly, for port 80,
that is the default port
for HTTP traffic.
So same idea, somebody
sends an HTTP request,
by default, that
goes into port 80.
And we say, great, port 80 is
OK under certain circumstances.
Now, right now, we don't
have anything in place.
It just says, any traffic
can come in from anywhere.
But conceivably, we
could add in anything
if there was like
password protection
or whatever that might be.
We're not doing that
for this right now.
But it's just to say that
we're only allowing traffic
through these.
That means that
if somebody tries
to come in with any
sort of other traffic,
it's not going to be allowed.
This is the same reason
I said if you wanted
to open up or build a
website on your laptop
and it's hosted
from your house, you
would have to go into
your home network
and open up a port
to allow traffic in
and also to allow traffic out.
By default, we typically
allow all traffic out
because that says,
hey, from my computer
or from my EC2 instance,
I can connect to anything
on the internet.
So great.
Now, let's pull
that back up then.
I'd say that, that was
from the machine side.
And so what I was getting
at is Apache as well
has its own firewall in place.
So by default, nothing
is allowed through.
So once we enable
our firewall, we
will not allow any traffic
in through anywhere.
So you can check that by
saying sudo ufw status.
Notice, right now, our
firewall is inactive,
but we're going to enable
it before we launch,
or before we connect to this.
One of the first
things I do though is I
do sudo ufw allow SSH.
This is important.
And this can-- this has
caused me a lot of headaches.
If you forget to enable SSH
in the firewall, the SSH port,
that port 22 on the
firewall, then what'll happen
is if you ever close
out of this terminal
and try to reconnect
to your instance,
it's going to be restricted.
I do not allow traffic in
through SSH connections.
And since that's the way we
actually open up our instance,
we can't even edit
it or change it
because we've just
disallowed it entirely.
So be very careful with this.
We don't have access to
the physical machine,
so the only way we are
connecting to it is through SSH.
And so we want to make sure
we keep that port open.
So I always allow SSH.
And then I say sudo ufw enable.
And notice, that's going
to note, it's going to say,
hey, you could disrupt
your SSH connection.
It's OK because
we've allowed that.
It's active and
enabled in our system.
And now, if I do sudo ufw
status, it should show that.
OK, great, port 22 is
allowed from anywhere.
Now, we also need to
allow access for Apache.
So we'll do sudo
ufw allow 'Apache'.
Will do quotation marks there.
And then finally, we want to
allow traffic through port
80/tcp.
So now if I do my
sudo ufw status,
notice that we now allow traffic
in through port 80 as well.
That's our HTTP traffic.
So our firewall has to
be enabled in this case.
And then also on our machine,
the security incident
or the security group has
to have port access enabled.
In the future, you'll
use tools that handle
a lot of this on the back end.
So we'll primarily focus
on our security groups.
But in the case of Apache, we
need to enable this ourselves
as well.
But again, if you
ever run into issues
where you try to
connect to your website
and it's not loading up
at all, just spinning
and it just doesn't seem
to be loading anything,
or it says, 403
access forbidden,
I would check right
here on your console
and make sure this is enabled.
Or similarly, if you go to
connect to your EC2 instance,
try to SSH into
your EC2 instance,
and it says permission denied
or not, access denied, whatever
it says there, I would come
over here to the security rules
and check that this is enabled.
If you need to
enable it again, you
can always come over here,
click the security group,
go down to inbound rules,
edit inbound rules,
and you can add a rule.
So for example, if
SSH wasn't there,
you would just come in here,
click SSH and select everywhere.
But it's already enabled,
so we'll just ignore that.
So coming all the way back
now, pull up my terminal again.
So we've now enabled
our firewall.
And Apache actually, by
default, puts a website live.
So pretty sure if we just
click open address right now,
we should see a default page.
Don't quote me on this.
Let's see here.
Bet, this is why.
There you go.
So all I did was I clicked open
address where you can literally
copy and paste that
into your URL bar here.
And notice that it
was just hanging here
and it wasn't loading up.
And my hunch was correct.
If you click into
your URL bar twice,
you'll notice that it's
trying to use HTTPS.
And as we just said, we did not
enable traffic through HTTPS.
The default port, I
think, is 443 for that.
And we also have it
enabled the certificate,
so this wouldn't work.
So if I backspace out that
HTTPS and just do HTTP--
it's terrible to say it
over and over again--
and hit enter, then it
pulls up to the default page
and lets you know,
hey, it works.
You are connected to your
instance, your EC2 instance
via website now.
But we want to have some
actual content on there.
So if you do
cd/var/www/HTML and type ls,
this will bring up
your index.html.
And that is the page.
If I do nano index.html
or vi, whichever--
let's do vi, since I can't
remember which you guys have
been using more often than not.
Either one works.
You'll see that this
is the actual HTML
page we just saw there.
So at the top--
let's see, where's the title?
Apache2 Ubuntu
default page up here.
All the text that's in
that page is shown here.
And so I'm just going to
click escape, colon, and q
to back out of that.
But now, let's say I
want to change that.
I want to put my
own text in there.
I want to put my own
website in there.
Very easy to do.
I'm going to use nano this time.
Nano again is just
another text editor.
So nano index.html.
Actually, before I do that,
I'm going to delete this file.
I don't want to have to
backspace all that out.
So I'm just going to
do sudo rm index.html.
We have to do sudo because the
var folder is not, by default,
accessible by a user account.
And so we basically
have to have root level
permissions to do that.
So that's why I'm doing sudo rm.
Now, I'm going to do
sudo nano index.html.
The reason I'm doing sudo--
I should have probably
done it before this one
before the vi command.
It didn't matter because
I didn't edit the file.
But if I tried to edit
and save the file,
it would have thrown
an error because I
don't have permissions to
edit the file as just my user
account.
So again, need root
level permissions.
I'm going to edit the file.
And now, it's blank.
It doesn't say anything
because we deleted the file,
so we're recreating
it as a blank file.
So now, we can just
type in some HTML code.
And we'll say--
OK, this is going
to be a really bad website.
You guys know I'm not
a graphic designer.
But it'll say, my first
website, body, and HTML, great.
And then we'll do Control
x, and yes, and Enter.
And now, if I refresh this
page, you can see here,
it says my first website.
And you can pull it up on
your phone as well, too.
So if you have your phone
live or next to you,
you should be able to
open up this website
on your mobile device
because it as well is just
a website, a publicly
available website now.
So typing it in, let's see
if this lets me show it here
on the screen.
It's very small.
But you can see it's
going to be blinking
in and out of existence.
But right here, it shows my
first website on that page.
So it's now live.
It's a publicly available
website, so great.
We've got that now, but we
want it to be interesting.
Again, I'm not a web
designer, so I'll actually
show you what I did here.
So if we open up--
I have it somewhere.
Let's just open it up here.
If we just open up
chat.openai.com and then--
I actually did this right here.
I just uploaded my
resume and I said,
can you create a
professional but minimal HTML
only, resume-based website or
resume based off of the attached
PDF for me to host on a server?
And so I just uploaded an
old version of my resume,
hit the Run button.
I copied this code here.
And we can do this right now.
So let's copy this code.
And then I'll come
over-- and obviously, you
would need to do
this on your own.
So use ChatGPT,
or Google Gemini,
or whatever tool you want to.
Or just go find a resume
template online at HTML only one
and you can copy and paste that.
But either way, I'll copy
this one here that I created.
Come back over to
my terminal and I'll
say sudo nano index.html again.
And so now, I'm going to
replace all of this text
with this long HTML.
So there's going to be
a lot of text in here
and it's going to look a little
scary, but it's all good.
So we're just going to paste.
And notice, this
is all that HTML
that ChatGPT just
created for me.
And then again, to save on
nano, you click control x,
and say yes, and hit Enter.
And now, if we come back over
to this website, hit Refresh,
and you got yourself a pretty
slick looking resume now.
Not the fanciest.
But there will be
an exercise for you
to play around with
and see, or there
should be an exercise
for you to play around
with and try to expand on this.
But to give you a short version,
this is just a HTML now.
So you could go in and
you could say, all right,
I want to create all sorts of
different variations on this
or edit things.
I could edit the text in there
by just editing that HTML file.
I could start to add style
elements by integrating CSS.
And I'll leave it to you guys.
Again, this is not a
web development class.
There's a whole separate series
for that in our department,
so you're welcome
to look at that.
But if you want to
on your own time,
you're welcome to pull on out.
And that's also my
phone number if you
need to call, text, email.
But I'll leave it
to you guys if you
want to look at CSS for styling,
JavaScript for interactivity
and expanded functionality
of your website.
So this is a real way you can
go and build and launch, host,
deploy a live website.
Again, like I said,
this is no different.
I can pull this up on
my phone right now,
hit the Refresh button.
And if it shows up
here, you can see
that I got the same file there.
Sorry, it keeps blinking
out of existence.
But it's all to say, this is
a relatively straightforward
process.
Few button clicks, and
we've got ourselves
a live website accessible
anywhere in the world.
You can certainly go steal and
mask it with a real domain name.
But I'd say that even just
from this little bit alone,
it's starting to make
a lot of progress
and show a lot of capability
if you can already do this.
So play around with
it, experiment.
You're not going
to break anything.
to ruin anything.
Worst case, if it doesn't
work, you delete the instance,
you start it over from
these steps again, so yeah.
Last thing I want to show you
how we can obviously clean up
any resources we've used.
The only thing we've done so
far is launch an EC2 instance,
so this is relatively easy.
We're going to come over here
once we're done with this.
Note that again,
once you delete this,
your website will
not be live anymore.
Also, if you stop this
instance and then restart it
next time, you will get
a different IP address.
So it'll keep changing that.
So there is a whole thing
on elastic IP addresses
that allow you to
assign a permanent IP
address to an instance.
Again, not
necessarily right now,
or if you're just going to
leave this live the whole time,
but keep that in mind.
So you terminate.
And it's in the
shutting down state.
But otherwise, we're good to go.
So we'll leave it at that.
And next time, we'll pick up and
enhance the website capabilities
and functionalities even more.
So thank you, guys.